I WONDER WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORTING
TONIGHT THAT SOMEBODY MAY HAVE
TIPPED OFF INVESTIGATORS ABOUT
THERE STILL BEING MORE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
WE'VE PLAYED A LOT OF THE
MONTAGES ALL THROUGHOUT THE DAY
OF THE IDEA OF REMEMBER THIS
COMMENT ABOUT THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT?
BUT I ALSO REMEMBER A LOT OF
COMMENTS ABOUT THOSE WHO MIGHT
BE LEAKERS, THE IDEA OF
SNITCHES, THE IDEA OF PEOPLE
INFORMING AND THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HIS REACTION
IS GOING TO BE THIS REPORTING IF
THAT IS, IN FACT, THE CASE?
>> LOOK, IT'S DEFINITELY THE
CASE.
HOW DID THEY KNOW?
LOOK, AS YOU STATED ACCURATELY,
WHEN I RECEIVED THE KNOCK ON THE
DOOR FROM THE FBI, FROM THE
AGENTS WITH THE WARRANT, YOU
KNOW, I OPENED UP THE DOOR.
I GREETED THEM DESPITE WHAT
DONALD SAID IN MY SPECIFIC CASE,
AND OF COURSE HE'S PARROTING IT
NOW, WHICH IS THAT THEY
RANSACKED THE PLACE.
THEY DESTROYED IT, THAT THEY
WERE UNPROFESSIONAL.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT TRUE.
THE FBI IS ALWAYS PROFESSIONAL.
THEY'RE COURTEOUS, AND THEY'RE
RESPECTFUL, AND I'M SURE THEY
TREATED MAR-A-LARDO THE SAME.
REST ASSURED IT'S ONCE AGAIN
DONALD PLAYING THE VICTIM.
BUT AS IT RELATES TO WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE, DONALD KNOWS THAT
THERE ARE LEAKERS OR PEOPLE WHO
ARE -- I'D LIKE TO SAY DOING THE
RIGHT THING FOR THE RIGHT
REASON.
I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
BUT WHATEVER IT IS, EVERY SINGLE
PERSON THAT HE COMES IN CONTACT
WITH, AND THAT INCLUDES HIS OWN
CHILDREN, HE HAS TO BE WONDERING
WHO IS IT THAT PROVIDED THE
INFORMATION TO THE GOVERNMENT
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN
THIS WARRANT?
BECAUSE YOU COULD BET YOUR
BOTTOM DOLLAR IN ORDER TO GET
THE WARRANT, THIS THING WAS
SCRUTINIZED AND SIGNIFICANTLY.
>> I ALSO WOULD ASSUME THAT EVEN
IF SOMEBODY WERE TO TIP OFF,
THERE HAD TO HAVE BEEN SOME
LEVEL OF CORROBORATION BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, UNLIKE, SAY, THE
AVERAGE PERSON, WE KNOW FULL
WELL THAT PART OF THE ABSURDITY
OF THE IDEA OF IF THIS COULD
HAPPEN TO TRUMP, IT COULD HAPPEN
TO ANYONE, IS THAT IT HAPPENS TO
EVERYDAY CIVILIANS ALL OF THE
TIME.
I MEAN THE IDEA OF AN EXECUTING
OF A SEARCH WARRANT HAPPENS ALL
OF THE TIME.
THE IDEA, THE NOVELTY IS IT
HAPPENED TO A FORMER PRESIDENT
HERE.
BUT ON THE IDEA OF YOUR OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE OF BEING AT
THE RECEIVING END OF THIS
FEDERAL SEARCH WARRANT, I MEAN,
I WONDER HOW DO YOU THINK THAT
TRUMP IS PERSONALLY REACTING TO
HAVING MAR-A-LAGO IN PARTICULAR
SEARCHED BY FBI AGENTS?
I MEAN, THIS IS -- HE'S EVEN
SUGGESTING THAT THE FBI MAY HAVE
PLANTED EVIDENCE, WHICH IS --
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER
ABOUT THAT.
>> OH, MAN.
YEAH, AND AREN'T THEY SUPPOSED
TO BE THE PARTY THAT PROTECTS
BLUE?
I MEAN TO MAKE A STATEMENT LIKE
THAT, IT'S SO RECKLESS, AND IT'S
SO DESPICABLE.
I TRULY DON'T EVEN WANT TO GIVE
IT ANY AIR TIME BECAUSE IT'S
JUST -- IT'S JUST WRONG ON EVERY
SENSE.
BUT ONE THING FOR CERTAIN,
DONALD'S NOT SO MUCH CONCERNED
THAT THE FBI CAME TO MAR-A-LAGO.
HE'S NOT.
WHAT HE'S CONCERNED ABOUT IS HE
KNOWS WHAT INFORMATION EXISTS IN
THE BOXES THAT WERE TAKEN, AND
THAT'S WHAT'S CONCERNING HIM.
THAT COUPLED WITH WHO IS IT THAT
WAS PROVIDING THE INFORMATION,
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW HE FEELS
TRAPPED.
HE FEELS ALL ALONE, AND HE
SHOULD.
HE SHOULD FEEL THIS WAY BECAUSE
REST ASSURED WHATEVER THE PERSON
THAT PROVIDED THE FEDS WITH THE
INFORMATION, THEY'RE WILLING TO
PROVIDE MORE, AND THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO UNTIL
ULTIMATELY -- AND ONE THING YOU
KNOW.
WHEN THE FEDS RAID, USUALLY WHAT
COMES AFTER THAT IS AN
INDICTMENT AND INCARCERATION,
AND NOBODY KNOWS THAT BETTER
THAN I.
AND ONE THING ALSO WHEN IT COMES
TO DONALD, I LOVE HOW HE'S
PLAYING VICTIM, RIGHT, FOR THE
WEAPONIZATION OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I HAVE A BOOK THAT I'M GOING TO
BE MAKING AN ANNOUNCEMENT
TOMORROW REGARDING A NEW BOOK OF
MINE THAT'S GOING TO BE COMING
OUT THAT DEALS EXACTLY WITH THIS
ISSUE.
THIS IS DONALD TRUMP'S
WEAPONIZATION OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOW COMING BACK TO
BITE HIM IN HIS EXTREMELY LARGE
BACKSIDE, RIGHT?
AND I CONSTANTLY PUT IN MY
TWITTER FEED, #KARMABOOMERANG.
HE'S THE ONE THAT CREATED THIS.
AND WHAT HE'S DOING IS USING
EXACTLY WHAT HE DID TO MYSELF
AND OTHERS IN ORDER TO PLAY THE
VICTIM ON.
IT'S REALLY AN AMAZING WAY OF
DEFLECTING.
>> WELL, EITHER YOU KNOW HOW TO
READ TEA LEAVES OR YOU'RE
EXTREMELY PRESCIENT ALREADY TO
HAVE A BOOK GO ABOUT THIS VERY
TOPIC, MICHAEL, I GOT TO TELL
YOU.
IT'S FASCINATING TO THINK ABOUT
IN MANY RESPECTS, THAT FOR SOME,
AS YOU'VE ARTICULATED, THERE'S
NOT THE SURPRISE ABOUT THE
PLAYBOOK THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
THERE ARE REMNANTS AND SORT OF
BREAD CRUMBS LEADING UP TO HOW
WE'VE SEEN THIS PLAY OUT IN THE
PAST.
I DO WONDER HOW IT'S GOING TO
PLAY OUT POLITICALLY GOING
FORWARD.
REALLY IMPORTANT TO HEAR YOUR
INSIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU KNOW, SO ONE QUICK
STATEMENT HERE.
>> SURE.
>> THE PROBLEM -- I'M NOT
PRESCIENT.
I'M NOT NOSTRADAMUS.
WHAT I AM IS FAMILIAR WITH THE
MAN, ALL RIGHT?
I WAS WITH HIM FOR OVER A
DECADE.
HOW DONALD TRUMP ACTED AT THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION IS IDENTICAL
TO HOW HE ACTS OR ACTED WHEN HE
WAS PRESIDENT IN THE OVAL
OFFICE, AND IT'S EXACTLY HOW HE
CONTINUES TO ACT POST HIS
PRESIDENCY.
NOTHING WITH THIS MAN CHANGES.
HE IS EXACTLY THE SAME TODAY AS
HE WAS TEN YEARS AGO, AND THAT'S
WHY I'M ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
INSIGHT THAT I DO AND SO
ACCURATELY, BECAUSE THE MAN WILL
NEVER CHANGE.
THINGS HE DID AT THE TRUMP ORG
IS EXACTLY HOW HE'S BEHAVING
TODAY.
>> CAN I ASK YOU, MICHAEL, I
KNOW WE'RE OUT OF TIME, BUT IF
THAT'S THE TRUTH -- AND I DON'T
HAVE ANY DOUBT THAT IT IS -- WHY
DIDN'T YOU SEE IT SOONER?
>> YEAH, BECAUSE I WAS BLINDED
BY THE CULT OF DONALD TRUMP.
AND IT WAS ALSO NOT AS RELEVANT
AS IT IS TODAY.
YOU KNOW, IT'S ONE THING WHEN
IT'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES MAKING A RACIST, SEXIST,
MISOGYNISTIC, XENOPHOBIC,
HOMOPHOBIC, ISLAMAPHOBIC,
ANTI-SEMITIC COMMENT.
IT'S DIFFERENT WHEN IT'S THE
PRESIDENT OF A SMALL REAL
ESTATE -- A MYOPICALLY SMALL
REAL ESTATE COMPANY IN NEW YORK.
EVERYBODY ALWAYS KNEW THE KIND
OF PERSON HE WAS, BUT THERE WAS
ALSO A LOT OF GOOD THINGS GOING
ON AT THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION,
AND SOMEHOW OR ANOTHER, MYSELF
AND ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES, WE
WERE ALL IN THIS CULT OF DONALD
J. TRUMP AND THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION.
WHEN HE ULTIMATELY LEFT THAT
ROLE AND BECAME THE PRESIDENT,
THERE WERE THINGS THAT I WAS
UNABLE TO CONTEND WITH, AND
THAT'S REALLY ALSO NOT WHAT GOT
ME OUT OF THE CULT.
WHAT REALLY GOT ME OUT OF THE
CULT WAS THE INCARCERATION.
>> MICHAEL COHEN, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HONESTY.
NICE SPEAKING WITH YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU, LAURA.